okay my mom is a mom how are you get on
my tan come on get here mom hi Tim mom
Gary stay there
swell hair girl i sat there
you look beautiful tan mom how do you
stay so tan at this time of the fire
yeah listen what your Kimble no Kimmel
that's a different guy in BO are you
what [ __ ] are you know what yes it
was Kimmel
well greenroom that she doesn't like
Jimmy why don't you like I know why you
don't like me because I made fun of you
at the Howard birthday party but the
truth is I couldn't hear what you were
saying I had no choice
nobody ever does it quite frankly I
don't give a damn what's the nicest
thing you could say about it yeah I
think you're very nice person
oh my god ten [ __ ] I'm sorry Jimmy buggy
let's go buddy
Wow I'm just trying to make Sal jealous
okay alright he's trying to horn in on
my action
Oh security get away hey mom calm down
go ahead let you marry go this is now
you loved a you love Jimmy let's get a
picture Jim you back home party hours
oh boy is this where mom wears on camera
y'all straight am i right mommy all
right oh there we go I think Jimmy just
had a baby so they just babe you tan mom
thank you grandma
oh wow what what Howard give tan mama
hug come on go ahead I'll come out and
see you okay we're gonna kind of hug
this woman she won't leave come on come
on we'll get we'll be morrow
maybe line up a great fight a Mon ha ha
thanks for coming to the party